♪ ♪
>> Jessica: LIBERAL LEADERS
BEING ACCUSED OF SELF CRIME.
THE STORE WORKER JOSE ALBA BACK
HOME AFTER THEY ALL LOWERED BUT
STILL FACING A MURDER CHARGE.
THE ALTERCATION WITH HIM
STABBING A MAN BEHIND THE
COUNTER AND SHOVED INTO A WALL.
CRIME IS UP OVERALL IN THE CITY
AND THE NYPD COMMISSIONER THINK
REPEATED OFFENDERS COULD BE TO
BLAME.
>> WE SEE A NUMBER OF PEOPLE
REARRESTED FOR THE SAME OFFENSE
IS OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
GRAND LARCENY LEADS TO MANY
INCIDENTS OCCUR THEFT.
WE HAVE SHOPLIFTING, MULTIPLE
SHOPLIFTING THAT WILL TURN INTO
A ROBBERY.
AND WE ARE SEEING THE SAME THING
OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
>> Jessica: THE SPOT LATE ON
JOSE ALBA'S CASE PUTTING
PRESSURE ON LIBERALS TO ACT.
MAYOR ADAM LEMING IDEOLOGY FOR
THE CRISIS.
>> THERE ARE TWO BATTLE THESE
GNOMIC BATTLES HAPPENING IN THE
COUNTRY RIGHT NOW, YOU HAVE THE
FAR RIGHT THAT STATES GIVE
EVERYONE A GUN NO MATTER WHAT
APPEARED TO HAVE THE FAR LEFT WY
EVERYONE THAT USES A GUN SHOULDT
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
THESE TWO GROUPS ARE NOT THE
MAJORITY OF AMERICANS.
AND THEY HAVE ACTUALLY HELD OUR
COUNTRY AND CITY HOSTAGE.
THESE TWO GROUPS DON'T REALIZE
THEY ARE COCONSPIRATORS TO THE
PUBLIC SAFETY CRISIS WE ARE
FACING IN THE CITY AND COUNTRY.
>> Jessica: SO WE'LL GO TO YOU
FIRST IN TERMS OF THE CASE, JOSE
ALBA CASE AND THE WORKER,
WINNING THE SELF-DEFENSE CASE?
>> Judge Jeanine: EXCELLENT.
IN FACT THE GRAND JURY, THEY
MIGHT SAY THERE WAS A
PROBABLE CAUSE FOR INDICTMENT IN
THIS CASE.
LOOK, WHAT YOU HAVE GOT IS GANG
BANGING CAREER CRIMINAL SEVERAL
STATE PRISON WHO COMES IN AND
HIS GIRLFRIEND TRIES TO USE A
DEBIT CARD THAT DOESN'T WORK.
HE JUMPS OVER THE COUNTER,
KNOCKS THE OWNER OVER.
THE OWNER DOESN'T HAVE A RECORD.
AND THEN PUSHES HIM.
THEN, HE PICKS HIM UP AND PUSHES
HIM AGAIN.
WHEN HE PULLED HIM AND TAKES HIM
OUT OF THERE, THAT IS WHEN THE
GUY THE VOTE TO GET GRABS A
KNIFE TO DEFEND HIMSELF.
HE DOESN'T KNOW WHERE HE'S GOING
AT THAT POINT.
THE UNFORTUNATE PART OF ALL OF
THIS, LOOK, YOU HAVE A GUY
CONFRONTED WITH A GUN HERE.
THE BODEGA OWNER SEVERAL MONTHS
EARLIER.
SO HE KNOWS PEOPLE HUMMING
SERIOUSLY.
I HAVE TO SAY ONE MORE THING
BEFORE WE MOVE ON AND I WILL BE
QUICK.
THE MORE I HEAR THIS GUY, JOSE
ALBA THE LESS I LIKE THIS GUY.
WHAT IS THIS?
WE HAVE COCONSPIRATORS.
IF ANYBODY IS A COCONSPIRATOR,
YOU ARE!
THE REASON FOR THE MAYOR IS A
COCONSPIRATOR IS BULIMIA ON THE
LEFT, BLAMING IT ON THE RIGHT,
"AS IS YOUR FAULT, YOUR CITY,
YOU ARE A CALL.
YOU KNEW WHEN YOU RAN YOU
PROMISED YOU WOULD TAKE CARE OF
GUN CRIME AND MURDER."
YOU HAVEN'T DONE A THING.
YOU WILL GO AFTER THOSE RUNNING
FOR OFFICE, AND REPEAL IT AND
YOU WON'T DO IT WITH ANDREA
STEWART'S COUSINS IN ALBANY.
YOU WANT TO GO TO EVERY HOMICIDE
IN THE CITY AND HOLD A SIGN UP
AND SAY BECAUSE OF CASHLESS
BAIL, THIS MURDER HAPPENED.
AND I WON'T GO ON!
BE TO JOEY QUESTIONING
>> Joey: NUMBER ONE, THE
GRUESOME NESTS OF BEING STABBEDE
PREVENTED WITH A GUN.
A MUCH MORE HUMANE TO DEFEND
YOURSELF.
THAT IS NUMBER ONE, NUMBER TWO
IF THE GUN LAWS SO RIDICULOUS A
SHOP OWNER AND CAN'T HAVE IT,
SHOP OWNER TO DEFEND HIMSELF
FINISHING THE GUN TO TURN AROUND
AND GO THE OTHER WAY.
SO A DETERRENT IN A LOT OF WAYS
PEER THE FACT IS YOU WILL SEE
MORE OF THIS BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
NOT GOING TO PUT UP WITH
LAWLESSNESS.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO PUT UP
WITH HAVING THEIR OWN LIVES
THREATEN FOR SIMPLY RUNNING A
BUSINESS.
THEY WILL NOT PUT UP WITH A
GROUP, A CLASS OF AMERICANS WHO
THINK THEY CAN IMPOSE THEIR WILL
ON WHAT THEY PERCEIVED TO BE THE
WEEK BECAUSE NO CONSEQUENCE.
HOW MANY PEOPLE NEEDLESSLY NEED
TO DIE AT KNIFEPOINT BEFORE THE
D.A.'S PROSECUTING PEOPLE AND
PUTTING THEM IN JAIL FOR SMALLER
CRIMES.
WHO WILL SAY THAT MAN'S LIFE?
WHOEVER LET HIM OUT OF JAIL.
HE WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN ON THE
STREETS TO PERFORM THE NEXT ACT
OF VIOLENCE BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
SLAPPING SOMEONE ON THE HAND AND
SAYING, YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'VE HAD
ROUGH BREAKS IN LIFE.
YOU SHOULDN'T BE IN THIS
POSITION WE WILL LET YOU BACK
OUT.
THAT DOESN'T PREVENT CRIME.
BUT IT WILL GET YOU KILLED IF
YOU OPEN A SHOP WITH A BODEGA
PIER THAT WILL GET YOU KILLED.
>> Jessica: GREG, WE HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT THE KIND OF MOMENT
ABOUT YES, THESE ARE PEOPLE
RETURNING TO THE STREETS PEER
THAT IS WHAT THE COMMISSIONER
WAS ACKNOWLEDGING THERE.
I WOULD LOVE YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THAT AND ALSO THE POINT IT WAS
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC THAT GOT
THIS GUY OUT ON BAIL BECAUSE
THERE WERE SUCH PUBLIC OUTCRY
THAT THEY LOWERED THE BALED TO A
REASONABLE AMOUNT TO GET HIMSELF
OUT THERE.
YOU SEE MORE ROLES FOR PEOPLE
LIKE US TO MAKE SURE THAT
JUSTICE IS SERVED.
SERVED.
>> Greg: AS MUCH AS I DESPISE
JESSE WATTERS...
[LAUGHTER]
HE MAKES ME SICK TO MY STOMACH!
THE FACT HE GETS TO TAKE FRIDAYS
OFF BECAUSE HIS BACK HURTS.
WHAT IS HE DOING?
HE IS SITTING WHILE WE ARE HERE
YELLING AND SCREAMING, HE IS OFF
HAVING A MARGARITA.
YESTERDAY, HE IS THE ONE THAT
SAID AND I HAVE TO GIVE HIM
CREDIT, WE HAVE TO STAY ON THIS
AND GET THIS GUY OUT.
AND I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE
WATCH -- WE ARE THE NUMBER ONE
SHOW IN HISTORY!
I BELIEVE, BOTH TELEVISION.
JOEY, FACT-CHECKED THAT BUT I
BELIEVE WE ARE THE NUMBER ONE
SHOW IN HISTORY.
AND HE SAID THAT.
WE HAVE TO KEEP ON THIS, KEEP ON
THIS AND LO AND BEHOLD,
"THE NEW YORK POST."
THINK ABOUT THIS.
THIS IS THE THING IN AN
ALTERNATIVE UNIVERSE THAT WILL
INFURIATE YOU.
WHAT IF THERE WAS NO TAPE?
>> Judge Jeanine: EXACTLY!
>> Greg: THEY WOULD HAVE TAKEN
THE STABBED SUSPECT.
HE WOULD BE A MARTYR.
THERE WOULD BE A MURAL, THERE
WOULD BE A MARCH PEER THERE
WOULD BE RIOTS IN THE BODEGA
WORKER WOULD BE PRETRADE AS A
MONSTER.
>> Judge Jeanine: AS A
RACIST...
>> Greg: THANKFULLY, THIS IS
WHY I AM NOT -- I AM
PRO-SURVEILLANCE, BODY CAM, PUT
IT EVERYWHERE.
IF YOU DIDN'T SEE THIS, YOU KNOW
EXACTLY THE TYPE OF NARRATIVE.
YOU KNOW WHAT, BIDEN WOULD HAVE
SPOKE OUT AGAINST THE BODEGA
GUY.
IF YOU WOULD HAVE SAID THAT IS
THE BODEGA GUY THAT HAS TO PAY.
LOOK WHAT HE DID TO THE
INNOCENT!
HE IS GETTING HIS LIFE BACK
TOGETHER.
EDDIE GET STABBED BY A MONSTER!
>> Jessica: KATIE?
>> THE IDEA THERE WAS BAIL AT
ALL FOR JOSE ALBA AND THE
CRIMINALS THEY LET OUT WITH NO
BAIL AND THE FACT HE IS BEING
CHARGED AT ALL IN A SITUATION
WHEN THERE IS VIDEO IS
ABSOLUTELY RIDICULOUS AND WILL
MAKE HIS LIFE MUCH HARDER IN THE
FUTURE.
MOST PEOPLE, ESPECIALLY PEOPLE
WORKING IN CRIME-RIDDEN AREAS
LIKE NEW YORK CITY WOULD RATHER
BE JUDGED BY 12 THAN CARRIED BY
SIX.
IT IS A LOT EASIER TO DO THAT TO
LIVE IN AN AREA ALLOWED TO
DEFEND YOURSELF WITH A FIREARM
AND TO MAYOR ADAMS TO COME OUT
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BODEGA
WORKER, GOOD THING.
BUT HE'S DONE NOTHING TO OFFER
ANY KIND OF DETERRENT TO THESE
CRIMINALS WHO AREN'T AFRAID OF
THE SYSTEM.
THEY ARE NOT AFRAID OF THE COPS.
THEY ARE NOT AFRAID OF THE
PROSECUTORS, OBVIOUSLY, RUNNING
BACK THROUGH THE SYSTEM AS A
POLICE OFFICER WAS SAYING.
THE ONLY THING THEY ARE AFRAID
OF IS SELF-DEFENSE.
THE MAYOR OF NEW YORK CITY IS
PREVENTING PEOPLE FROM BEING
ALLOWED TO DEFEND THEIR OWN
LIVES FROM PEOPLE WHO WALK IN
AND KNOW THERE WILL BE NO
CONSEQUENCES FOR THEM BECAUSE
THE MAYOR AND EVERYBODY ELSE ARE
ON THE SIDE OUT OF THE BODEGA
WORKERS TRYING TO MAKE AN HONEST
LIVING, BUT THE CRIMINALS IN THE
CITY RUNNING THE SHOW.
>> Greg: THEY DO CHARGE FOR
POTATO CHI